[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette édition
du 7 8 les invités nous sommes
aujourd'hui le jeudi 29 juin 2017
je suis ravi de vous retrouver bonsoir
l'open de golf fait désormais partie des
huit événements de la rolex séries qui
réunit les tournois les plus prestigieux
du tour européen il est construit sur le
modèle original d'un stade de golf qui
permet un vaste public de bien voir le
spectacle
les 308 députés république en marche ont
fait leur rentrée mardi dernier au
palais bourbon
didier baichère député de la première
circonscription des yvelines faisait
partie de ces nouveaux arrivants et pour
commencer du golfe avec l'ouverture de
l'open du golf à saint quentin en
yvelines nous retrouvons michael et me
d'euros qui est avec christophe muniesa
le directeur technique national de la
fédération française de golf
michael bonjour stéphane alors nous
sommes actuellement sur le golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines et à côté
de moi la ryder cup que l'open ne compte
que la golf national accueillera dans
deux ans en 2018 mais avant de parler de
la ryder cup nous allons parler de
l'open de france qui vient de débuter
ici donc dans ce golfe et pour parler de
cette compétition qui a commencé sous
les chapeaux de roue christophe muniesa
le dtn français du golf français à 7 me
les a on pouvait pas rêver mieux pour
cette première journée
non effectivement une bonne journée de
lancement c'est la 101e édition une
histoire une preuve historique du
calendrier européen
effectivement on pouvait craindre
quelques intempéries qui aurait pu
perturber le jeu mais ça s'est
parfaitement lancé avec déjà de très
très bons scores
quelques français bien passé pour
ménager le suspense pour le week end
trépidant qui s'annonce les stars qui
sont présentes sur l'open de france
vraiment ont marqué le coup aujourd'hui
elles répondent présentes tout
simplement
oui on peut penser notamment un grain
mcdowell joueurs nord-irlandais qui
s'est déjà imposé à deux reprises dans
cette épreuve
il ya également alex noël le joueur
suédois qui est actuellement des
meilleurs joueurs européens qui a gagné
la première épreuve des rolex et reese
l'open de france bénéficiant pour la
première année de ce label de rolex
series et puis des français j'évoquais
notamment alex lévis le meilleur
français cette année qui a fait un très
bon 69 inaugural de en dessous du par il
est très bien placé il ya d'autres
jeunes pousses aussi est tel que
s'allier qui est parfaitement placé
après ce premier tour le vainqueur tant
que j'aille dit pour l'instant n'a pas
brillé aujourd'hui
non non il reste en embuscade tendue à
abidjan il dit mais effectivement il
n'est pas aux avant postes et les
français du coup avec son earl et victor
dubuisson est ce qu'ils peuvent
remporter cet open de france qui a été
remporté déjà par un français en 2011
par thomas levet est ce qu'ils peuvent
succéder à thomas levet cette année oui
thomas levet en 2011
avant lui en 2004 2005 c'est jean
françois remesy qui s'était imposé ça
fait maintenant donc depuis thomas
quelques années que l'épreuve échappe
aux français alex levy est le joueur le
plus en forme du moment
greg bourdy s'est déjà illustré à
plusieurs reprises dans ce tournoi il
est aussi plutôt bien parti pour cette
nouvelle édition
donc évidemment on y croit c'est encore
un peu tôt pour faire un pronostic ce
n'est que le premier tour le tour final
se déroulera dimanche mais les français
ont fait plutôt une bonne entame
sur ce premier tour il ya donc une
nouvelle dotation cette année avec le
groupe h chili qui a qui sponsorise
l'open de france
le sponsor à injecter de l'argent s'est
passé à 7 millions de dollars
qu'est ce que ça change concrètement
alors ça rend le tournoi encore plus
attractive pour les meilleurs joueurs du
monde à l'image par exemple de john ram
le joueur espagnol qui fait ses débuts
sur le european tour
il est déjà 11e joueur mondial ça
renforce donc l'attractivité du tournoi
ça permet aussi à l'épreuve de gagner
une date de choix de garder pardon une
date de choix dans le calendrier
européen et ça permet aussi à l'épreuve
de tester le parcours un an avant la
ryder cup vous l'évoquez et de susciter
l'intérêt aussi des joueurs américains
qui viendront sans nul doute recueillir
le reconnaître par dont le parcours en
2018 avant l'épreuve de la ryder cup
on sent également une nouvelle dimension
au niveau de l'organisation il ya un
sens de presse maintenant il ya
également des infrastructures qui ont
été construites autour de nouveaux
parkings
on sent vraiment courante à un an la
ryder cup finalement dans cette ryder
cup oui cette épreuve de la chaîne à
l'open de france fait un peu office de
répétition
il faut savoir que sur une journée ici à
l'open de france on accueille jusqu'à
20000 spectateurs par jour alors que sur
la ryder cup
on dépassera les 50 mille spectateurs
jour ce qu'ils ont fait l'événement 2
golf le plus attirant le plus de public
la ryder cup donc à la fois l'open de
france c'était un événement à part
entière avec son identité propre
il ya effectivement une montée en
puissance qui se ressent dès cette année
une exposition médiatique accrue
et puis tous les éléments qui font aussi
le succès d'un événement les services
spectateurs le dispositif de sécurité il
ya une véritable montée d'une marche
supplémentaire lors de cette édition
2010 est de l'open de france
dernière question est ce que vous êtes
prêts à organiser la ryder cup est ce
que vous êtes prêts dans l'épreuve mais
très clairement ça fait maintenant plus
de dix ans qu'on s'y prépare avec les
équipes du european tour sachant que
cette année sur l'organisation pratique
de l'open de france c'est le european
tour aussi qui a pris le relais
ce sont eux qui organiseront compter de
la fédération française de golf sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
la ryder cup l'année prochaine donc oui
on est plus que prêt on est chaud et on
a hâte que ce grand événement soit
accueilli ici sur le parcours du golf
national
merci beaucoup créé 5 milliards et je
rappelle pour les téléspectateurs l'open
de france se termine ce dimanche à saint
quentin en yvelines
nous retrouverons prochainement pour la
suite de cette compétition
nous passons à la politique avec les
premiers pas je vous le disais de tous
les nouveaux députés élus le 18 juin
c'est le cas notamment de didier
baichère le député de la première
circonscription des yvelines il est au
micro de nicolas danger nous sommes ici
à l'assemblée nationale dans la salle
des pas perdus en compagnie du député de
la première circonscription des yvelines
didier baichère à bonsoir bonsoir
alors comment se sont passés vos
premiers pas à l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment la rentrée
des classes la première journée en
séance un moment très solennel en fait
pour le vote du président de l'assemblée
nationale françois de rugy qui était élu
la majorité c'était un moment très très
émouvant beaucoup beaucoup de fierté en
fait d'être là et de pouvoir représenter
les gens de la circonscription
alors maintenant le travail va commencer
quel député vous serez moi je serais un
député concentré je pense que on est
très nombreux à être nouveaux donc on
découvre le travail de l'assemblée
ce matin on était là à 8 heures pour
notre première réunion du groupe la
république en marche
donc on est déjà très concentré sur le
travail il ya ainsi un nombre de
commissions à mettre en place donc on a
été réparti en fonction de nos voeux
dans les commissions donc en ce qui me
concerne je suis très fier d'être à la
commission défense puisque savez que
j'ai fait campagne aussi bien sûr la
commission sociale que c'est la
commission défense
je suis très très fier d'avoir obtenu
cette commission sur quels projets du
président emmanuel macron et du
gouvernement edouard philippe vous allez
travailler sur la thématique de la
défense moi je vais être attentif au
budget de la défense je savais que à
versailles en particulier on a un
problème de logement de nos armées qui
est un sujet qui est en place et qui se
disputent depuis de très nombreuses
années mais les crédits ne sont pas
déboucher enfin débloqué pardon donc je
veux que ça débouche donc je vais
m'assurer avec le ministre de la défense
et ministre de la défense que c'est des
budgets vont enfin être débloqué et
qu'on va pouvoir rénover ces logements
je m'attacherai aussi parce que sur la
circonscription il ya beaucoup de
sous-traitants du secteur de la défense
et je m'attacherai ce que la région
parisienne soit enfin reconnue comme un
territoire de défense pour que ces
entreprises puissent aussi se développer
correctement sur notre circonscription
une autre thématique qui doit vous tenir
à coeur de par votre expérience de drh
c'est la réforme du code du travail donc
le projet de loi d'habilitation à
procéder par ordonnance a été présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres
comment vous allez contribuer à cette
réforme
alors ce qui est essentiel c'est qu'on
est sur une modulation une innovation en
matière de modèle social c'est pas que
le code du travail parce qu'il ya aussi
l'abaissement des charges pour les
salariés
entreprises ce travail d ordonnance va
être essentiel vous savez que c'est un
dossier technique pour minimiser
en tout cas aller beaucoup plus vite et
minimiser les allers retours entre le
sénat et l'assemblée
donc moi je vais très attentif également
à ce dossier parce que il faut qu'on
flexibilise notre droit du travail il
faut qu'on le simplifie travailler dans
une très grande entreprise vous
travaillez dans une petite entreprise et
la très très grande majorité de nos
salariés nos entrepreneurs sont des
entreprises de moins de dix salariés ont
besoin d'un code du travail beaucoup
plus flexible beaucoup plus simple pour
pouvoir recruter et innover correctement
en france donc c'est à ça que je vais
m'attacher des entreprises qui seront
qui sont concernés notamment dans votre
circonscription comme vous l'évoquez
avec la thématique de la défense
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez est-ce que
vous avez souhaité rassurer les salariés
qui sont peut-être inquiet de voir cette
réforme procéder par ordonnance par le
gouvernement est ce que vous allez les
rassurer dans votre circonscription
bonne voie les ordonnances est quelque
chose d extrêmement technique sur le
fond la négociation avec la ministre du
travail a déjà largement commencé avec
les partenaires sociaux
nous notre rôle de député ça va être
peut-être beaucoup plus que par le passé
d'être dans la pédagogie
donc comme je lé fais pendant ma
campagne moi je vais être sur le terrain
avec les entrepreneurs qui voudront nous
rencontrer avec les commerçants avec les
grandes entreprises pour expliquer quel
est le travail que nous voulons donner
qu'est ce que nous voulons simplifier
pour eux s'il faut rencontrer également
les représentants des salariés
c'est de ce jeu que je ferais bien sûr
volontiers que je fais depuis 25 ans
donc ça sera pas une difficulté pour moi
alors la semaine prochaine
edouard philippe le premier ministre
edouard philippe doit faire son discours
de politique générale c'est sur moi un
autre moment solennel je suppose dans
votre début de carrière de député
oui c'est un moment qui est très très
attendu je veux dire que ce week-end
comme nous étions en séminaire
l'ensemble du groupe la république en
marche
nous avons eu l'occasion de
d'avoir déjà une présentation du premier
ministre est un vrai échange et j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un personnellement je ne
le connaissais pas j'avais eu jamais eu
des changes avec lui j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un de d'extrêmement simple dans
l' écoute aussi des parlementaires qui
étaient là et qui a envie de partager le
travail du gouvernement est lui aussi
d'être dans la pédagogie
donc je suis très optimiste sur ce
discours de politique générale et on
sera là pour soutenir l'ensemble du
gouvernement les députés de la
république en marche
on les a souvent accusés d'être des
amateurs accusés ont décrit comme des
amateurs parce que c'est des nouveaux
députés est ce que ce sont vraiment des
amateurs ou après les échanges que vous
avez eu ce week-end lorsque lors du
séminaire vous êtes rassurés et puis
même vous c'est la hauteur de vos
espérances
oui oui complètement je pense qu'on est
pas confondre être pour la première fois
député être amateur l'ensemble des
personnes qui ont été élus je vous
rappelle qu'on a été tous élus très très
largement dans nos différentes
circonscriptions
on a chacun des compétences et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on avait été
sélectionnée pour être candidat et ses
compétences qu'on a exposé aux électeurs
donc chacun dans notre domaine on a des
compétences extrêmement précise et
pointue on est très nombreux à venir de
la société civile donc de connaître nos
dossiers et c'est ça qui va faire la
différence
une dernière question comment se déroule
le travail entre les membres du groupe
la république en marche le groupe
parlementaire la république en marche
est ce que vous vous entendez bien tout
c'est ce que c'est il ya des débats qui
se crée entre sein du groupe mais tout à
fait un méchant j'ai entendu beaucoup de
bêtises
depuis le début de la journée sur
comment se passe le travail à 3 à plus
de 300 députés
moi j'ai trouvé un un richard ferrand
dont il est le président de notre groupe
très à l'écouté des questions parce
qu'on est aussi débutant sur certains
sujets techniques donc pas vraiment
expliqué à prendre le temps de faire
cette pédagogie de comment nous allons
travailler chacun pour s'exprimer
il n'y a pas que des votes à l'unanimité
c'est là où j'entends beaucoup de
bêtises et chacun a pu dire ce qu'il
pensait réellement son envie de
s'abstenir on s'abstient son envie de
voter contre on vote contre
donc c'est un échange et un vrai débat
entre nous c'est la fin de ce magazine
7,8 les invités merci de votre fidélité
de nos reportages sont à retrouver sur
notre site internet tv fil 78 points com
ou sur notre application tes fils 78
bonne soirée
[Musique]